he's been good he took a no-hitter
oh
came out of the game after having
thrown a no-hitter in his first start
and didn't get to finish that off and
did a nice job his last time out as well
for him to continue that josh donaldson
is back at third base
actually playing in the field for the
first time remember he got a hit and his
first at baton left the ball game so
kiki lead things off in center field
here for game two quick turnaround for
these clubs just 30 minutes in between
games
that's to left field
and a diving attempt by garlic he knocks
it down thankfully
and that's pretty much how
game one ended
with alex verdugo their left fielder
making a catch on a similar ball off the
bat of luis garage yeah good effort here
by garlic but the thing that he did that
was so important we saw cordero in the
first game
kind of hit this ball off his body this
one garlic still even though he wasn't
able to catch it was still able to knock
it down with his glove so good
concentration right there alex verdugo a
game saving catch
about a half hour ago robbing a rise of
an rbi and a hit we'll see if this one
follows
play at second got it out on the first
got two they turn the double play
so two away here in the first
with the shift on moving parts it was
hit to a rise but not polanco covering
its second base instead donaldson went
over
jd now
17-45 so he's at 395.
and the one-two swag and a missing down
he goes on a curveball barrio strikes
out martinez and jose sees the minimum
in a scoreless first inning scarver
against a left-hander will take over the
lead-off spot see if the twins can break
a four-game losing streak
twins have done a lot better against
left-handers than they did last year so
far eduardo five innings against the
orioles very emotional for him jerry it
certainly was so it certainly wasn't no
walks in that game and seven strikeouts
you would think he'd be much more
relaxed today than he was in that game
yes he has that going early he struck
him out with it
another good change up two back-to-back
change-ups
to pick up the strikeout for rodriguez
once again almost in the exact same spot
down the way just off the outside edge a
little bit
donaldson back in the fold from
minnesota when healthy very dangerous
hitter
two for two still hitting a thousand
and donaldson gets the first base hit of
the nightcap
maybe that's the spark the twins need
having him back in the lineup two and
two with one down and donaldson at first
in the bottom of the first eddie throws
and cruz swings and lines went down the
right field line over and to his left
comes verdugo and that dunks in for a
base hit going to third is donaldson
verdugo's throw there is not in time
foot first slide for donaldson a seeing
eye single down the right field line and
the twins have them at the corners with
one away twins have runners at the
corners on a single from cruz with one
out
they have scored five first inning runs
trying to add on
a 3-2 count to garlic
and the pitch will swing into line drive
left center field coming in hernandez he
is there to make the catch donaldson
will tag and try for the plate the throw
comes in donaldson scores standing
so donaldson testing out that hamstring
right away in this first inning running
the bases running hard sprinting 90 feet
and the twins are on the board in a
garlic sack fly it's a one nothing twins
lead two down made the throw but it's
done not going to be in time
to get donaldson certainly deep enough
throw tailing up that third base line a
little bit put so much on that throw and
the throw kind of pulled vasquez into
foul territory off the third base line
so donaldson scores cruz stays at first
garlic with his third rbi
polanco right center field that's headed
to the gap brews around second he'll go
to third and polanco's aboard with a
base hit and the twins have three
singles and at least one run here in the
first
so a
walk to donaldson nelson cruz will bat
cruz lifetime against rodriguez 3 for 18
with a home run pitch swing hard shot to
short grab by bogarts under hand to
second on the first and they turn it
over
so the twins threat goes by the boards a
big double play
six four three
a one upper right at sander and the side
retired after three one nothing twins
need a ground ball double play right
here as the twins and double play depth
dugo at second with a big lead one ball
one strike in the ground ball
and a ground ball caught by
barrios and he'll throw to second
and he'll double up verdugo at second
base it was a line drive that kind of
reached back reacted
and caught it and then quickly through
to a rise of strike
bats here with a count of two balls one
strike
wins one in the bottom of the first
inning there's a line drive over the
head of devers down the left field line
it's going to be fielded by cordero it's
going to get by him as polanco into
second base he'll pull up there
cordero got into the corner where the
cutout is
comes back out and hit he got right
there when the ball was hitting the
padding
he slowed it down
and trickled about five 10 feet past him
behind kepler 2-0 there's a swing and a
fly ball center field that should get
him out of it it's more of a short stops
ball and bogart's about 10 feet back in
the grass makes the catch to retire the
sides so
eddie pitches around the lead off rubble
we go to the fifth barrios has been
dominant today he's been fortunate too
three balls no strikes to cordero with
the bases loaded and one out
and that's ball four and the ball game
is tied
that'll bring in rafael devers
still only one out base is reloaded in a
1-1 game that's gonna be it for him as
good as he was throwing in this ball
game today
never did i expect him to leave after
five
bases loaded now two down and here's
verdugo
line drive and a base hit into right
field
vazquez in to score dalbeck right behind
him
he scores
verdugo continues to have a big big day
and the red sox lead it three to one
first and third for jd martinez he is
the eighth man to hit in the inning
check swang did not make contact and
another run is in on the wild pitch
throw it to second base not in time the
red sox add on another run for dugo down
to seconds here comes devers who really
has been good today 1-1 to raphael
he waited on that and he smacks it into
right field for a base hit
one run in two runs in debra's jumping
on that give him two more rbis and the
red sox lead in six to one he's been a
memorable double header here in
minneapolis for alex verdugo and there's
a rocket pulls this one wickedly out of
here gone in a heartbeat well have
yourself a day mr verdugo home run here
to make it a 7-1
red sox trying to put the finishing
touches
on a double-header sweep
0-2 and a ground ball to third endeavors
up and over and that does it the red sox
have ripped off nine consecutive wins
and they sweep the doubleheader against
the minnesota twins